premier fait marquant c'est intervenus
au tout début du meeting alors qu'eric
zemmour traversé la salle pour se rendre
là sur scène et là il s'est fait
agresser par un homme le gars c'était
l'homme élastique dans les casses
monétique j'ai jamais vu à ce le gars y
avait des bras me faire arrêter sans
déconner il était il s'était passé à
mille pattes il était à toulouse le gala
a regardé truc de ouf
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
apparemment c'est à son fils non je fous
le gars a dû préparer son coup c'est
incroyable karim et ses violentes ça
surprend il leur il paraît qu'il ya huit
jours d'itt et et eric zemmour et le
poignet cassé le poignet un oeuf jouera
d'ailleurs jour ça vient de tomber
gilles c'est ce qu'on dit c'est assez
incroyable alors c'est prémédité il a
sur ce qu'il crée tout de suite ce qui
va arriver avec comme ça après garde à
vue alors il risque gros seins parce que
évidemment plus a toujours dit avait dès
cet été alors il faut dire c'est à plus
de 7 jours d'itt et et voilà un risque
quoi à plus de la 9 jours d'itt et et on
risque trois ans de prison et 45000
euros d'amendé pour violences aggravées
avec préméditation et guet-apens
exelmans a porté plainte alors il n'aura
pas ça mais le risque est gros surtout
si on détermine que par exemple c'est un
militant d'extrême gauche qui avait
prémédité et qui a vraiment voulu lui
faire très mal les images seront
analysées une enquête est ouverte alors
il a 27 ans vient de colombes sur
l'agression à son nom c'est valentin
abdellah dgid ndjeng abdel majid il est
actuellement en garde à vue pareil pour
violences volontaires avec préméditation
et guet-apens ayant traité 1 et entraîné
une itt était de plus de huit jours donc
est ce que le jeu en valait la chandelle
et à son visage sur paris réseau ouais
y'a une vidéo on le voit très bien et
tout le monde a son temps mais
franchement c'est honteux fossé c'est
dingue de faire sa cellule et j'espère
qu'il va trinquer parce que c'est pas
possible de faire ça on est en
démocratie les gens doivent s'exprimer
et ce qui vient d'arriver là c'est nul
et pour répondre à votre question est ce
que le jeu en valait la chandelle
clairement non feinte conquois d'accord
en tout cas merci d'avoir tout serait
pas la notion abdelmajid 1 il avait
changé de prénom pourtant tout allait
bien pour lui
et ça passe au figuré unités en phase
avec les revendications du canada c'est
vrai qu'ils ont dû voir ça au meeting
sont unis dans sa passe est en fait
voilà mais c'est vrai que voilà en tout
cas c c'est incroyable de voir des
scènes comme ça on aura d'autres scènes
parce qu'il ya des scènes incroyables
lors de ce meeting dès le début de son
discours eric zemmour s'en est pris
directement à ses adversaires il a eu
des mots très forts même un peu trop
fort selon certains regardent et il ne
se passe pas une seule journée sans que
les le pouvoir et ses relais médiatiques
ne m'attaque il me traite tous les noms
mais ne vous méprenez pas le véritable
objet de leur courroux ce n'est pas moi
c'est vous s'il me déteste c'est parce
qu'il vous déteste s'il me méprise c'est
un style vous mais présent contre moi
tout est permis la meute est désormais
lancée à mes trousses mes adversaires
veulent ma mort politique les
journalistes veulent ma mort sociale et
les djihadistes veulent ma mort tout
court
alors
quelqu'un qui est fans d'eric zemmour
est ce qu'il a réussi son entrée
parce que c'était soit ça près entrée en
politique avec eric zemmour bale et
lennon ben oui parce que on n'a pas été
arrêtée de taxer lui et son équipe
d'amateurs en disant qu'il n'arriverait
pas à fédérer derrière etc et en
quelques jours ils ont changé de sa
leçon à l'as villepinte ils ont réussi
quand même à mobiliser quinze mille
personnes en tout 13 il est il
s'agissait de faire une démonstration de
force en l'occurrence ils ont fait une
démonstration de force après on aime ou
on n'aime pas mais en tout cas ils ont
réussi il a réussi ça il avait moi je
pense une base beaucoup de choses qu'il
fallait balayer parce que c'est ça ça
toussotait sa part ça partait mal avec
gilles bouleau ça s'est mal passé etc
etc il fallait absolument que ce meeting
là en tout cas ils sont un coup de poing
ce soit fort et à mon sens il a réussi
alors il ya plusieurs fois voulu se
défendre contre l'image qui peut avoir
et il a énormément parler du racisme
d'ici là dit à chaque fois on m'accuse
d'être raciste et il y avait un petit
truc aussi va voyons c'est bien servi
ben voyons exactement regardez
racistes alors que
je suis le seul à ne pas confondre la
défense des nôtres avec la haine des
autres
le racisme qu'est ce que c'est c'est
s'imaginer que ceux qui sont différents
de nous sont inférieurs parce qu'ils
sont différents et que ne pourraient
être français que des descendant en
droite ligne de clovis comment
pourrais-je comment pourrais-je penser
cela moi petit juif pervers venu de
l'autre côté de la méditerranée
non évidemment je ne suis pas raciste
non évidemment vous mais pas raciste
tout ce que nous voulons c'est défendre
notre héritage karim il a réussi son
premier jeu tu me mobilise depuis de dix
mille personnes dans le contexte il n'y
a pas beaucoup de politiques qui peuvent
le faire moi j'ai rien d'urgent lui que
j'ai rien de commun avec zemmour mais
jean-luc mélenchon il a rejeté ces mises
en avait mille dehors donc qu'il est à
peu près 5000 mais quand même dix
minutes plus de dix mille personnes et
puis est-ce que tu as évoqué tout à
l'heure 2 millions 400 mille personnes
qui le suivent devant la télé ça à
dimanche après midi les stocks les
zemmouris sortie d'une longue séquence
avec le doigt d'honneur marseille l'a
pas vue à marseille et et gilles bouleau
et là il lui fallait réussir ce meeting
et en termes d'organisation a parlé
violente reviendra tout à l'heure il y
avait du monde il a déroulé son
programme avec ses obsessions
immigration islam et identité toujours
pareil et les gens qui étaient là pour
lui était contente donc quelque part
pour lui c'est une empreinte campagne
réussie alors il a parlé de aussi on
pourra parler de ceux qui l'accusent
d'être misogyne s'est servi de son
parcours personnel pour leur répondre
regarder et puis je serai misogyne alors
là savaient à quel point cette
accusation est ridicule enfants au
milieu de ces grandes familles venues
d'algérie j'étais toujours entouré par
des femmes c'est ma mère qui m'a
inculqué le goût de l'effort et de
l'excellence c'est grâce à son
expérience et à ses souvenirs que j'ai
pu comprendre avant d'autres la
régression inouï que les femmes
subissent aujourd'hui dans des quartiers
où une immigration de masse à importer
les civilisations islamiques
[Applaudissements]
mais pendant ce temps là les féministes
détourne le regard et nous parle
d'écriture inclusive
alors un discours de tryba mélenchon la
même réalité d'ailleurs
campagne où ils sont tous anesthésiant
de propos convenus faut reconnaître que
lui comme mélenchon ils ont des vrais
discours de très bonnes donc chacun ils
me l'ont toutes raisons de rassembler
dans les semaines à venir parce qu'ils
ont le sens de la punchline donc ça vous
a plu le meeting où le meeting non mais
le discours je m'en fous mais le
discours le discours et les banques et
le discours et gabriel et rien d'aisé
réussi bon pour moi le lancement de la
campagne réussie en dur à dire alors il
ya le fond et la forme sur la forme
c'est plutôt spectaculaire vous l'avez
dit la salle est pleine c'est un peu on
reconnaît l'esthétique des grands
meetings de sarkozy c'est ça ça c'est
très ailleurs
lui qui se dit que ça qui fait c'est le
même qui organisait ces mêmes jeunes qui
se débrouille très bien sur scène il
n'est pas du tout emprunté on l'a mis
pour la première fois un prompteur et
par excès enfin moi je sais pas il
paraît que c'est difficile un prompteur
quand on est un homme politique je
trouve qu'ils se débrouillent plutôt
très bien attendez pas donc fonctionner
sur la forme je trouve que c'est plutôt
c'est plutôt réussi après sur le fond
pardonnez moi moi je trouve que c'est un
échec parce qu'on fait que je n'ai rien
retenu apparue ultra violence à part les
échauffourées à part à part le fait qu'
il a des idées mais en fait les idées
ont elles sont complètement broyé par le
chaos qui celui-ci part par la violence
qu'il génère est donc finalement pour
moi ça fait un peu cheap voilà alors
c'est un homme tout l'écho comme tout
candidat il paraît que dans un discours
pareil d'un meeting à paris qu'il faut
frapper c'est un peu tout le monde c'est
la règle est à la fête il en a profité
pour fracasser le président emmanuel
macron 1 je pense c'est cet été on les
verra pas la quatuor
la personne emmanuel macron ne nous
intéresse pas parce qu'elle est
fondamentalement inintéressant mais moi
un seul français dans le pays qui puisse
expliquer la pensée des manuels macron
un seul
il n'y en a aucun pas même lui personne
personne ne sait qui il est parce qu'il
est personne en 2017 la france a élu le
néant et elle est tombée dedans
ce mannequin de plastique cet automate
qui errent dans un labyrinthe de miroirs
ce masque sans visage qui défigurent le
nôtre nous laisserons cet adolescent se
cherche et éternellement
alors vers la rochelle ça te touche
mémoire de journaliste politique j'ai
tous écouté ce week-end mais ils sont
extrêmement choqués ça n'est jamais
arrivé là on s'attaque aussi violemment
au président de la république
fait du trop hâte à choquer toi
tout me choque chez lui donc ma parole
du gouvernement
non dit ce qu'il veut laisser démocratie
chez moi j'espère que les gens vont bien
se rendre compte de l'homme qu'il est du
danger qu'ils représentent karim s'est
senti choqué non mais avec une
expression aussi violente comment on
peut appeler un apaisement il ya un
respect de ratios naissance d'un
possible oui en fait générateur de haine
il est générateur de roger les
générateurs de fracture on ne parle pas
comme ça du pied droit public il n'a pas
dit un mot des mesures qu'ils auraient
pu contester du prénom république on
peut critiquer la politique du prix
d'ami ne critique pas la politique et le
trail de mannequins et le traitent faits
l'adolescent de tous les noms sur sa
personne et bien sûr sa politique c'est
un non sens a dit c'est de l'irrespect
total et la réussite mais là on moi j'ai
répondu oui on se retrouve au niveau
médiatiquement parlant parce que moi
j'ai passé des heures sur les réseaux a
tous regardé et c'est vrai que et c'est
malheureusement grâce ou à cause c'est
selon son point de vue des opposants
parce qu'au final toutes les vidéos
qu'on a vu pour moi médiatiquement ça a
vachement marché parce qu'il ya des
millions de vues sur ce genre de vidéos
toulon dans le progrès que quand on voit
visuellement le rassemblement est basse
et c'est beau esthétiquement c'est à
dire que les gens sont
il a bien fait son truc comme on dit
tout à l'heure avec gégé bien c'est bien
c'est très bien organisé et ça a été
tellement relayé que médiatiquement
parlant d'un film de nicholas toi tu
sais russie aussi pour toi alors moi je
dis que c'est un vrai succès médiatique
il ya une couverture incroyable
maintenant je pense qu'il n'a jamais
fait aussi peur aux gens c'est à dire qu
on a l'impression de retrouver un peu
l'image de jean marie le pen à l'époque
il ne respecte plus rien c'est à dire
qu'il est en train de monter son public
contre tout le monde contre le
gouvernement contre emmanuel macron
ferait perdre après il fait un acte
violent quand
on ne l'a jamais vue aussi dangereux n'a
jamais fait aussi peur c'est ce qu'on
dit c'est un succès par contre pour lui
je n'en suis pas persuadé pendant les
jours qui vont arriver